foreign
right now people living with
disabilities can apply for a program
that promises learning and potential
employment it's a cyber security class
this guy what is up with his hair I'll
tell you I could tell you what that's
plugs right that's the cheap plugs but
those are the bad plugs those are the
not the good plugs REM organizers tout
18 months of work Readiness training
after students complete it's like the
doctor did his hair put his hair plugs
under gunpoint yeah
course box size Alex whittler joins us
from the live desk to introduce us to a
student who just completed the class
yeah The Buffy Dodd Institute that put
on this program she's kind of cute aims
to illuminate possibilities this is just
one way in which it does so let's see
her dress looks like it's made of made
by hostess
Twinkie dress
Jerry Sutton will tell you people living
with different abilities can be
overlooked for just different abilities
is in the word different abilities would
mean like that like you can control the
weather and [__] are you yeah yeah
adamantium claws right right something
like that like you know yeah that's a
different ability even fireworks fingers
but but no that's not what you have
these are retards opportunities we're
giving up the X-Men are raping each
other again
you know why we call it the danger room
because if you go in there you're in
[__] danger yeah they're very
aggressive and very strong don't even
mention the danger room to [__] uh
Jubilee she still has [__] pts oh no
boys to people yeah they were raping her
and all she could do is shoot fireworks
so it just look like Fourth of July in
the danger room the only one who's safe
is Rogue yeah it's true it's true we
were often not heard that's why he and
others involved with the Bobby Dodd
Institute
inaugural cyber security program oh what
a crop
can't wait to see where students like
Ron Darius Jordan end up the computer's
our partner so the computer light can
help us like with some resources he's
gonna be fine he's just a gay black guy
just completed bdi's appropriately
titled Bridge Academy it's salty
engineer abilities like randomly seizing
and shooting their pants
turns neurodiverse students into
certified support technicians and
connects them to workplaces that can tap
into another candidate pool not only
dealing with individuals that are
autistic high functioning artistic
whether in a car accident or something
and became autistic
also have individuals such as a recent
stroke myself as you can see I was just
thought out six months ago but now
thanks to PDR I'm teaching other retards
that's kind of like Encino Man
candidates must be 18 be able to read
write and do math at a ninth grade level
well I'm out they're autistic trust me
they'll meet all them and have a high
school diploma or GED over 10 weeks
students become Cisco certified and by
the program which they make it means
they can sing all the words of the song
Thong Song
what a useless certification
what state is the
is this Atlanta
Georgia
Atlanta the county of Drew
Drew Hill with Cisco service
and also Cisco's part of the Wild Wild
West song from the Will Smith
programs and students [__] [__]
singing the thongs
these are paired with mentors I like it
when the Buenos today yes
break it down break it down break it
down now and keep cyber security jobs
many employers even in the small
business sector believe that it's going
to cost a lot of money to hire someone
uh with a disability because they're
gonna no they know what tax credits they
get you dumbass they're very aware spend
a lot of money on an accommodation but
according to the job accommodation
network if a candidate has to there's so
many of these weird like things like job
accommodation networks all these like
ngos
yeah exactly have I told you guys about
so in Toronto okay there's a there's a
doordash like alternative that exists
where it's a [__] person no delivers
you your food your order but they like
take the subway and [__] what is this
what is this called I don't remember
slow and steady
door hobble no food tortoise
Uber feet
I swear to God I didn't eat any of your
food
why is every restaurant just serving
pennies Ruby fingers Hub yes seriously
can I get a Can it can I get a lift eats
um he delivers your food and he's
licking his fingers
it's called Good Good Foot delivery
I don't
know one bite left oh
some fries missing
I'm a drool Dash
most of your order
oh most of you
it cost thirty percent less but you get
30 percent of the food so there's
boogers on my food what is that that's
on the house
we don't charge it extra don't worry
that's a garnish yeah yeah my food
arrived fine but like the delivery guy
just talked about dinosaurs in my
doorways dinosaurs I don't know want to
be rude oh [__]
calling it special deliveries a swift in
the chat that was right in front of us
all time
special delivery customer service yeah
so he got here and now he's here
at that time where I bring you the food
and now I live here
I fed you so now I am your mother
you touch my hand I am your assistant
thank you for calling special deliveries
customer service if you're calling about
boogers in your food press one if you're
calling about a [__] punching your
wall still for all other inquiries press
three
we're sorry you're having trouble
[Music]
hello welcome to a special deliveries
[Laughter]
it's all my [__] drywall is ruined
that's a shame where I am we eat dirt
we're gonna give you we're gonna go
ahead and give you a 2.50 credit off
your order with a drywall thank you
yep we know I had to make him dinner I
felt bad
I ended up cooking anyway
now he's just napping on my couch and
I'll be honest it's adorable yeah but I
can't keep them oh [__] he's dreaming
look at him he's dreaming it's like me
with cats look I can't keep him I got
enough retards look I'll feed him but
I'm not in the house he's gonna be an
outdoor [__] Jack had three where can
I find Sound of Silence Break It Down
video I've been trying to send it to my
friend at work oh what was his name oh I
don't know I always forget too I would
look through my old subscriptions on
YouTube but uh oh yeah why what happened
um
but bro it's tonight's night wave's
gonna be Brian hagaman it's gonna be a
[__] trying to navigate and do [__]
yeah your algorithm's all [__] gone I
have nothing yeah
well that's your shipping him with
rotcies as we have the RC Channel we
don't have the ROTC algorithm so I've
been using the clips one but it's
definitely not the same algorithm
which does kind of suck uh this is it
right
yeah this is it here you go here you go
guys oh friend break it down to talk
with you again telling you store break
it down because Aviation is awfully
creepy break it down hey somebody
leaving the comments for him to the
Thong Song thank you I want him to be
Cisco certified
bring it down bring it out all right we
could stop making fun of the retards I
feel bad